Imagine The Lego Movie and Deadpool got together
and had a PG-rated love child.
Well, they kind of did: it's The Lego Batman
Movie.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
If you're a Batman fan, then you'll quite
likely feel you've died and gone to Bat-heaven
when you watch the latest entry in the Lego
movie franchise.
With other fish to fry – hello, Han Solo
movie – Lego Movie directors Phil Lord and
Christopher Miller handed the directing reigns
for this film over to Chris McKay, who edited
and co-directed animation on the first movie.
McKay's production is a crazy, colourful,
irreverent ball of energy that races through
the Caped Crusader's many and varied incarnations
over the years as it spins a tale of dastardly
deeds by the Joker, while weaving in a story
of family and team spirit that, occasionally,
veers into sentimentality.
Never afraid to poke fun at itself, the Bat-legacy,
movie clichés, or the movie business in general,
the Lego Batman Movie channels the spirit
of 2014's super-successful Lego Movie and
throws into the mix the kind of barrage of
meta-gags and endless easter eggs so wickedly
brought to life in Ryan Reynold's Deadpool
movie.
In fact, you'll need more than one viewing
to catch them all!
And, of course, this being a Batman movie,
there's plenty of what you'd expect, including
tricked-out vehicles and costumes, and explosive
action.
Will Arnett returns as Batman after debuting
his own gravelly-voiced take on the character
in the first Lego film.
I loved Arnett as Gob in Arrested Development
and Devon in 30 Rock, and he certainly puts
his comedy chops to good use here, proving
yet again that he was the right choice for
the part of a preposterously pompous Dark
Knight who's in dire need of having his posturing
taken down a peg or two.
As for the supporting cast, Arnett's Arrested
Development co-star, Michael Cera, gives an
amusingly enthusiastic performance as Batman
fan-boy and side-kick Robin.
While Ralph Fiennes is fantastic as Batman's
butler, Alfred.
Rosario Dawson puts in a nice turn as Barbara
Gordon, jumping across to the world of DC
from the MCU where she's usually found as
nurse Claire Temple in Marvel's Netflix shows.
And as the voice of the Joker, Zach Galifianakis
gives a perfectly serviceable performance,
though I doubt it'll stay with you the way,
say, Mark Hamill's does.
On top of the main players, there's a ton
of cameos including loads of comic-book characters
as well as a varied bunch of individuals from
the wider world of movies and literature,
and I'll have a video on that soon as well
as the movie's cool connections and easter
eggs.
Now, if you're thinking, this movie is essentially
one big ad for Lego, well, in many ways, you're
not wrong, but there's certainly enough fun,
substance, and gorgeous visuals in the film
to mean it's more than just a platter to serve
up merchandise.
Though one thing I did find a bit grating
was the amount of over-the-top product placement
for a certain smartphone.
If you're looking for a lot of brick-building,
like in the first movie, you won't find it
here, which makes sense because construction
was a big part of the actual story in the
Lego Movie whereas here it isn't, and that
didn't bother me at all.
Oh, and you won't find a song either with
the same level of ear-worminess as Everything
Is Awesome, which, in some ways, is no bad
thing.
Instead, the soundtrack uses 80s pop to often
comical effect and composer Lorne Balfe does
a nice job integrating some rather familiar
superhero themes in his score.
To sum up: the Lego Batman Movie does a good
job continuing the entertaining franchise
kick-started three years ago by Phil Lord
and Chris Miller.
It's fun, often funny, silly, and crammed
full of cameos, connections and easter eggs
to the Caped Crusader's world as well as the
DC universe and beyond.
Yes, it does sometimes indulge in sentimentality,
much as its predecessor did, but there's much
to enjoy in Chris McKay's spin-off.
And as it's the first superhero movie out
in a packed year of super-flicks, I'm glad
to say we're off to a good start.
Fingers crossed things carry on that way!
Now, what did you think of the Lego Batman
Movie?
And who are your favourite DC superheroes
and villains?
Let me know in the comments below!
Coming up, I've got a Lego Batman easter egg
video and videos on the DC TV shows Supergirl,
Arrow, and The Flash.
If you enjoyed this video, do share it, and
subscribe for more reviews, Easter Eggs, and
crazy movie and TV facts!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!